66 million americans suffer from eye
allergies as i am right now actually and
have a difficult time finding relief it
doesn't matter whether you're outside or
indoors allergies seem to just be
everywhere so here's some information
that may help with relief
there is no hiding from allergies the
symptoms are unmistakable season starts
sooner and it seems to be going later
and i feel like i say this every year
but this is an especially bad year for
allergies i've had so many patients come
to see me they come in complaining of
the sneezing of the runny nose but
specifically in relation to their eyes
they'll complain of those red itchy
irritated eyes allergens can affect
people indoors and outdoors but the
cause is different outside is often when
things start to bloom so blooming plants
and trees that release pollen that gets
into the air and that can cause a lot of
irritation even ragweed and grass can be
common culprits and then inside it can
be things like dust or even pet dander
which can be found in the home and all
of that can contribute to eye itch
besides keeping the eyes clean what else
can you do what i recommend to my
patients is to use a drop which is over
the counter which is called pat a day
once daily relief extra strength and
that's really getting to the target
source as to why your eyes are itchy you
can visit pataday.com for more
information
there's more las vegas now after the
break and we will be right back